crap get face line oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh
what was that hey how's it going breasts
this is Pierre row well sorry
welcome back to lucious there's gonna be
the final part of this epic epic series
oh my god
there's no it's horn that wood from the
mountains is what's all hail the coming
of the new age one-third of the light
shining from the Sun the moment of the
stars became dark nice a lunar eclipse
graced the strife fittingly entering a
nearby research facility at the locust
farm fitting a glass room with nice why
is that building leaning though the Book
of Revelations predicted a fiery chasm
with a great cloud smoke rising up the
Sun in the air would turn black and the
swarm of locusts would emerge from the
smoke hey burn and the insects would
roam the fields I does not insect Brendo
didn't think of that do they stick
welcome back Lucius it's gonna be a good
one I hope my hair can handle the
green-screen this time
Hey Oh God Jesus Christ the whole place
is on fire what the hell are we gonna do
I think it was a kid that was doing it
[ __ ] with that out here there was
something not right there I'm not sure
what I saw but something wasn't right
why what do you mean Joe well this might
sound odd but I think I think the kid
was on the fire the whole time hey I
need to tell them to get the hell out of
there
and know that I know that voice who are
you job Gillman it's a noise doing I
don't know who you are jab Gillman but I
will kill users what was that what is
with your voice you can't tell me what
to do job can we make that into a
dynamite have some fertilizer job huh
would you like some fertilizer in your
face
boom whoa pimp it out pimp it out pimp
it out girl holy [ __ ] this is he just
standing in the [ __ ] foot video games
ready video games ladies brace I'll
leave my fertilize no wait for lice I
can explode I think don't worry about it
no more a body ah don't worry it's to
you don't worry but don't worry don't
worry bot so alright we made it in we
made it in safe flammable bottle ooh oh
oh oh yes I would like to make a play my
way
boom bada bing better been better been
more power me oh my god it keeps
exploding ah make it stop
that was fun let's do that never again
who another one wonderful another player
too
are they not dead yet
are you [ __ ] me alright we're gonna
have to do this like a bow see don't you
dare [ __ ] touch me
don't you [ __ ] there Lionel wrap your
face Lionel oh oh oh oh oh what was that
what was that that was beautiful
Thank You Lionel preciate it Lionel your
[ __ ] Lyla [ __ ] hate you
who saw it I need today
this other force all right but can't
free access with pizzas disappointment
hey you guys are [ __ ] dead aren't you
how about that that's great Oh know more
about him don't worry about all right
everything is on fire some do trim
outside all right I'm gonna guess that's
not good with flames what does it say
Oh is this water what the [ __ ] uh okay
all right who's seeing me someone is
seeing me now it wasn't me it wasn't me
don't [ __ ] touch me [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
you [ __ ] ass beat don't [ __ ] touch
me you bitch-ass [ __ ] but it'll explode
are you [ __ ] kidding me follow all
these [ __ ] flames can I pass I can
pass awesome
it's Locke though hey buddy just need to
kill him
all right I'll do that slippery to sleep
really yes they are
please a sandwich yes okay here we go
let's make that vicious sandwich
you want some slippery slick oh he's
slits lighting so sexy grab that donut
let's try grab the donut and then eat it
ah oh yeah a baby girl I will rock your
world baby girl it's not a baby girl
it's an old discussing man
okay here we go here we go much better
um how do we break that let's just go
behind him for now the fam
yes the fear perfect perfect
what do we got they try to put the fire
out huh some weed huh mmm research huh
get it get it
some fertilizing free the locust eye
free all the locust is your free locust
locust instead name Lucius look look it
was a plant on a long plot twist get it
okay now we need to kill Isaac yell
mayor or we need free locusts too as
well dammit how I don't like a copper
Burnett there it is
what does it do
drives to B's crazy sounds good yes they
are buddy you've been staring it there
it is
is he gonna die now uh that net died
death by bees
Nikki cage side all coming did me free
the locust free the local locust but how
Airness is that him that's him what damn
that voice acting is really creepy and
then voice sinking what is that corpse I
think
more colors she's a mess
she wanted this little old earth alright
I feel like this guy's making a lot of
sense have some sauce buddy
Pam bet you don't like salt [ __ ] oh man
he really didn't like salt Jesus I mean
Satan I don't know well that was fun
let's go and have a barbecue the sound
of the locust plan
well this is awkward well I better I
better go through free my life my last
locusts gotta freedom locust says
hashtag relatable there it is
cool what level completed all right corn
King killed
all right last level coming up Rose get
excited you out done that wasn't really
much of a fight was actions over this
much intelligence only wrote a blood low
he was able to see what havoc he created
on the small forsaken town the National
Guard had arrived and roadblocks were
put in place as a security measure it
was told martial law we waited for the
sixth and seventh trumpets to call out
the death of four angels mark the return
of the last angel and he would give the
scroll to the one first accepted it this
would be marked with a flank now it's my
skype thank you very much game the buses
are evacuating
to get out as well all right that was
[ __ ] Ken so blame that [ __ ]
here we go hey how's it going no chalk
for your baby how we're back here we
just have to kill people who are
defibrillator should we wait for them to
pass maybe it's always so fun killing
with these come on baby make me proud
baby come on
yes yes yes oh oh oh oh get that's what
happens that's what happens baby girl oh
these are all supposedly angels that's
[ __ ] stupid all right
how do we kill the rest of them some
money some cash have to say ish alright
that might be useful
toilet mallamma thank you
uh what the [ __ ] just happened am i
sitting on top of the baja what the [ __ ]
they even test this oh my god this game
is so flawless I don't even know all
right we have a lot of pliers so let's
make one of them follow me which one I
don't care you to the leg to the leg
everybody no you [ __ ] dying in the
leg
do-do-do-do-do-do-do we have another
player might as well seemed like the
easiest way to kill them oh god how do I
make him go there maybe if you ran
instead of walking you'd have a chance
but knew what the [ __ ] oh my God he's so
annoying what is wrong with him
ha do the leg Turner look that's how I
roll that time I get on the ladies thank
you
good champs have a nice life leg you're
free one more right you have another
plier no we don't uh what we do have
however is some gasoline can I just use
this
hey don't worry about it
I said don't worry about don't work but
hey why don't you why don't you take
grill your feet a little bit for me
he'll be great
he'll be green Elfi green dance Stan
Stan Stan Stan Stan Stan
dance dance dance and it's done we did
it first high five
I was reaching more angels oh my God
he's back am I supposed to hear what he
says or what is happening okay uh
Oh a badass nice hair though oh my god
don't kill me
I don't want today ow
[ __ ]
oh my god he didn't even get the
electrified ah
oh yeah the salt salt salt salt I have
sold him spare salt all day every day
you want salt in your face how do I get
there we go now we can get the gun
okay I understand out that's what I'm
talking about that's how I get all the
ladies now what what you gonna amazing
reloading reloading baby I can't [ __ ]
click coz what I just see Oh mad shot
not really that's it that's your last
little penis slinging
one more shot and we got them no problem
no problem we're gonna do this press
we're gonna do it don't panic damn panic
now boom headshot oh oh oh oh oh no no
no no no no no it's not say it ain't so
no are you [ __ ] me oh my god not the
[ __ ] block don't cock-block me
he's cock-blocking me now what am I
supposed to do I can't yes shot him in
the dick
how are you not dead finish aah oh my
god [ __ ] I call [ __ ] I have one
more shot yes
don't you dare shoot me oh my god
read it out oh my god ridiculous
ridiculous
we [ __ ] dicks in my face Alice oh my
god how was he not finally dead last
time hey Fran teaches results I am
thoroughly impressed with you thanks
buddy thanks Ted
finally got his approver the sound of
the seventh trumpet signaled the third
wall this was the final trumpet send
loud voice of the needle have proclaims
the Antichrist have a nice just forever
though find the Z buzz since is this way
so let's check it out I suppose
I love buses chapter what level what
what's happening the rest of mankind you
were not killed by these plagues still
did not repent the work of their hands
they did not stop worshipping their puny
God always sneaked into a bus that was
evacuating the town I'm a passenger
suspected anything I haven't a suspect
to buy while sitting on the back seat he
looked down at the scroll he held in his
hand it was sealed with seven seals
these seals were not to be opened by
hand but by actions that would lead to
them melting away
he admitted through many tests the NAM
she wishes Williams kindness
I would continue to go
now Walter White let him taking steps
that was total gastrin we didn't suspect
it what what by killing seven people
oh it at convenient there's seven people
in the best
well got many songs and I will have many
more this one is special this one
continues to surprise me with his crafty
ways of delivering my wrath his
creativity is definitely without
comparison and he will be more than
ready to take us to all rap sure it will
be a thousand years of darkness as I
take my place with the mortals they will
learn to take judgment seriously and
Lucius I saw the Dark Prince
the little Antichrist thanks dad this is
the end
are you telling me it just ends like
that
that's quite a title
oh it's the people who made the game
this is a credit now that's that's
Walter White
don't lie to me oh how nice
damn it I can't pour gasoline in here
this is [ __ ]
well that was that was a Shh
that was a shitty ending wasn't it um
okay um okay um I'm just gonna I can't
do anything all right then I guess that
concludes our playthrough of the lucious
thank you for I don't want to talk like
that
Oh Bruce hey it's for the fun one hasn't
it I enjoyed playing have you enjoyed
watching with me I feel like yeah it was
a cool cool game it has a lot of
mistakes and it sure does a lot of
wonkiness but that just adds a little
extra spice to the flavor if you know
what I mean murdering people is fun and
I'm glad you saw that in me thank you I
believe at you thank you so much um yeah
it's been a while since we did Syria so
it was cool to keep this kiss from this
one up I'm value boys got so into it
that's all for me for now I ever am oh
god that was it was someone there that's
gonna creepy but for now we'll see press
it's Rufus for you stay us